what part of your body is the most
painful place to get hit right on the
nose when you get hit hard right here it
stinks pretty bad like even shots that
have got dropped with they hit my chin
or like body shot nothing compares to
getting hit Square on the nose and
you're still up and it just stings so
bad what sport would make the best boxer
probably basketball why do you say
basketball I don't know they're super
athletic quick on their feet they like
work on angles a lot I think they'll
probably be the best do you think hockey
fights have any hockey fights yeah do
you think they have any chance or no way
no it could might as well just be two
guys fighting at a bar who is your
favorite Instagram account to follow
Christiano Ronaldo what is your favorite
phone app to use besides text message
boxing timer because I'm always using it
or Lightroom to edit photos